there seems to be no let-up in the flow
of people into the city of by door in
southwest somali they've been displaced
by drought and most are hungry and
desperate the few medical facilities run
by agencies are full of sick and
malnourished children like most people
here norte eden madam had to walk more
than 10 kilometres to get help for her
sick child honestly new year
my son is a year old and has been sick
for two months i had to bring him here
for help i have no intention of
returning to our village till he's fully
recovered on the outskirts of the city
we meet more displaced people who have
just arrived during droughts in the past
many left it too late before moving to
seek help but that seems to have changed
the massive movement of people to the
cities has seen a huge rise in the
number of camps for the displaced in by
dora in 2016 there were just 70 such
comes today there are 435 of them with a
population of more than 360,000 people
that is more than the original
inhabitants of this city
eight workers say the world has failed
to respond adequately and they need more
donations forever measure or IDB the
numbers of those in need keep growing by
day and far outstrip the resources we
have the donors are trying their best
but we never seem to be able to catch up
with a growing number of displaced the
United Nations emergency aid coordinator
has been visiting by door he says people
here need much more than food aid pace
and development always a solution
ideally people have a chance to go home
and rebuild their lives it's not always
possible so then there's a question
often of land and access to services and
support where they've come to and
they're in that means there's a need for
a supportive discussion from the local
authorities some of the displaced told
us they've also fled the violence of
al-shabaab fighters who also forcing
children to join the group this crisis
is happening
as communities are already struggling to
recover from a two-year long drought
that ended in 2017 nomadic pastoralism
has been a way of life for millions of
Somalis for centuries but the droughts
are threatening but many of the
displaced say they now have no farms or
had to go back to and it's unlikely many
of them will ever return Mohammed Al
Jazeera Baidoa in southwest Somali